[Música]
the new york times' publicó de
documentos con los últimos 20 años de
declaraciones de impuestos del
presidente de donald trump el mandatario
reportó millonarias pérdidas en su
imperio empresarial para evitar pagos de
la renta federal la investigación señala
que por ejemplo solo pagó 750 dólares al
fisco en 2016
el presidente de azerbaiyán ilham alíev
decretó una movilización parcial de
recursos militares por la escalada de la
violencia en el enclave de nagorno
karabaj donde se enfrentan por este
territorio fuerzas azerbaiyanas y
armenios el líder de azerbaiyán prometió
no ceder en el conflicto hay al menos 39
fallecidos tenemos reporte desde moscú
y ya son más de un millón de fallecidos
en el mundo por kobe 19 en india del
país más afectado sólo superado por eeuu
ya hay más de 6 millones de contagios y
más del 95 mil fallecidos en américa
latina sigue la propagación del virus
caso de argentina pese al cierre más
prolongado de la región colombia perú y
méxico siguen entre los 10 más afectados
aquí comienza la mañana y también las
noticias de france 24 mi nombre es
ángela gómez buenos días iniciamos el
informativo en eeuu el diario the new
york times reveló información sobre las
declaraciones de impuestos del
presidente de donald trump con un
histórico de 20 años según la
investigación el magnate republicano
habría pagado tan solo 750 dólares al
fisco en 2016 y no habría pagado
absolutamente nada en los dos en 10 de
los últimos 15 años desde la casa blanca
del mandatario tildó la publicación de
noticias falsas informa andrés donde
publicaré mis declaraciones de impuestos
contra la voluntad de mis abogados
cuando ella publique los 33 mil correos
electrónicos que fueron eliminados del
líder el ministerio alrededor de las
declaraciones de impuestos de donald
trump viene desde hace varios años ahora
el diario estadounidense the new york
times' asegura haber tenido acceso a
información de dichas declaraciones del
magnate de las últimas dos décadas el
informe revela que trump no pagó
impuestos federales sobre la renta en 10
de los últimos 15 años ya que reportó
que sus empresas perdieron más dinero
del que ganar
y en 2016 año en el que resultó electo
pago al fisco tan solo 750 dólares
también una cifra similar en 2017 la
investigación revela además que el
presidente estaría bajo presión al
enfrentar deudas por cientos de millones
de dólares trump rechazó los hallazgos
del 'new york times'
son noticias totalmente inventadas y
falsas pasamos por las mismas historias
podrías haberme hecho las mismas
preguntas hace cuatro años tuve que
litigar esto y hablar de ello noticias
totalmente falsas en realidad pague
impuestos y lo verán pronto en mis
declaraciones de impuestos pero están
bajo auditoría la bancada demócrata
expresó su indignación donald trump es
un mentiroso un tramposo y un hombre de
negocios deshonesto pero también se está
aprovechando un sistema desigual roto y
corrupto que está diseñado para que las
personas como él hagan lo que hizo con
moción de conmoción es donald trump
autoproclamado multimillonario recibió
un reembolso de 72,9 millones de dólares
del servicio de recaudación de impuestos
mientras que no pagó ni un centavo en
impuestos federales sobre la renta en 10
de los últimos 15 años
donald trump es el único presidente de
la historia moderna de eeuu en haberse
rehusado a publicar sus declaraciones
fiscales y actualmente enfrenta
investigaciones por posible fraude ante
la fiscalidad de manhattan un nuevo
escándalo justo antes del primer debate
ente de trump y el demócrata joe biden
previsto para el martes
la noticia se conoció solo dos días
antes del primer gran debate
presidencial que por primera vez
enfrentará a cara a cara a donald trump
y a joe biden el encuentro será la noche
de este martes 29 de septiembre en la
universidad de case western reserve en
cleveland los candidatos aparecerán pero
con distanciamiento y en el escenario y
la audiencia será menor que en otras
contiendas con un máximo de 90
asistentes tras 24 transmitir en directo
este debate entre el presidente de
donald trump y el ex vicepresidente joe
biden usted conéctese con nosotros para
escuchar los argumentos de los
aspirantes a la presidencia de eeuu a
partir de las 8 de la noche ahora bogotá
quito lima
y cambiamos de tema azerbaiyán declarada
en ley marcial y en plena movilización
de sus fuerzas militares asume la
escalada de la violencia en el enclave
de nagorno karabaj a una región
autoproclamada como azerbaiyana pero
donde la mayoría de habitantes son
armenios y luchan apoyados por su vecino
país de procedencia las capitales
ereván y bakú se enfrentan en un
conflicto armado de origen histórico y
las víctimas mortales son al menos 39
matías arráez nos amplia
el presidente de azerbaiyán ilham alíyev
decretó este lunes una movilización
parcial en el país debido a la escalada
de las tensiones en el enclave de
nagorno karabaj el domingo al ayer
decretó también la ley marcial en todo
el país y un toque de queda en algunas
ciudades al intervenir ante el consejo
de seguridad del país el mandatario
prometió no ceder ni un ápice en el
conflicto con armenia azerbaiyán
azerbaiyán no llevó a cabo ninguna
provocación azerbayán está simplemente
defendiendo sus intereses apoyando su
posición y siguiendo abiertamente su
política hemos declarado repetidamente
que en aborto karabaj es la principal
patria histórica de azerbayán y en
cierto
sí ambos bandos se culpan mutuamente por
agresiones
los dirigentes del autoproclamado
independiente de nagorno karabaj dieron
un paso más adelante este lunes hablando
de la participación activa de otra
potencia de la región
quiero declarar que no solo azerbayán
sino también turquía está en guerra con
nosotros están usando las principales
armas y municiones modernas disponibles
en el ejército turco drones y aviones
en ereván apoyo mayor de nagorno karabaj
se reunieron centenares de civiles
dispuestos a dar una mano a su ejército
en las pocas horas que lleva el
conflicto ya son decenas las víctimas
fatales de ambos bandos a principios de
los años 90 el enclave fue escenario de
una guerra en la que murieron 30.000
personas desde entonces las autoridades
azerbaiyanas han tratado de recuperar el
control de la misma aunque se acordó una
pase en 1994 la querella territorial
siempre causó inestabilidad en la región
y desde moscú tenemos ampliación con
nuestro corresponsable xavier colás
buendía saber para ustedes y en contexto
cuál es el papel que juegan en este
conflicto territorial rusia y turquía
bueno pues ha cundido la preocupación
precisamente por eso porque tanto
armenia como azerbaiyán tienen a
importantes potencias militares detrás
en el caso de armenia es el país más
pobre de los dos que se están
enfrentando pero tiene el apoyo tanto de
rusia que incluso tiene una base en su
territorio armenia además forma parte de
una alianza militar en la que está
incluida rusia por otro lado
azerbayán es un país más rico al cual
las inversiones petrolíferas le han
permitido tener un ejército muchísimo
más grande y tiene también el apoyo de
turquía que aspira a aumentar su
influencia en esa región ambos países
turquía y rusia han cooperado en los
últimos tiempos en el plano de siria a
pesar de estar apoyando a bandos
distintos ahora estos dos pequeños
países que vivieron su última escaramuza
de importancia en el año 2016 recordemos
con más de 100 muertos por los combates
tratan de atraerse a cada uno de sus
grandes
socios para no perder ni un metro en
este disputado territorio de nagorno
karabaj ah bueno xavier y hablemos de
los riesgos que existen de que este
conflicto se extienda más allá de la
zona territorial de nagorno karabaj
pues es precisamente por eso por esas
alianzas en el caso de que armenia fuese
atacado ya estamos hablando del
territorio que ha sido reconocido
internacionalmente es decir en caso de
que los combates avanzarse hacia el
territorio de armenia armenia podría
reclamar que como un miembro de esa
alianza en la que está incluida rusia
sus fronteras fuesen defendidas pero no
hay que olvidar que en el otro lado en
el azerbayano ese gran socios a gran
potencia militar que apoya a los
azerbayanos es turquía y no hay que
olvidar que turquía es miembro de la
otan y la otan también tiene un artículo
similar el artículo 5 que obliga al
resto de los países socios a ayudar si
uno de ellos es atacado por eso nadie
quiere pensar en lo que podría ocurrir
si
el territorio turco hubiese atacado
durante este conflicto
gracias a ver por la información el
mundo alcanzó el millón de
fallecimientos por cueva de cuenta del
nuevo coronavirus y la propagación de la
enfermedad sigue a ritmo acelerado en
todo el mundo como ocurre en india país
que continúa mostrando un preocupante
ascenso son llamadas de 6 millones de
contagios y 95 mil fallecidos en el país
asiático sólo superado por eeuu que la
semana pasada sobrepasó 7 millones de
positivos
y américa latina sufre una continua
escalada de casos a pesar de que países
como argentina impusieron cuarentena
tempranas algunas de las más largas del
mundo los argentinos suman más de 711
mil contagios y 15.000 700 muertes y
están dentro de los 10 países de la
región más afectados en el mundo también
se encuentran en la lista brasil
colombia perú y méxico mientras tanto en
panamá tras más de 6 meses de bloqueo
reabren hoy los restaurantes y las
tiendas contra la crisis económica
desatada por la emergencia sanitaria
manaos la ciudad más grande de la
amazonas brasileño volvió a cerrar bares
y playas entre otros lugares ante un
resurgimiento de casos de kobe 19 la
situación pone en entredicho un estudio
de científicos internacionales que
indicaba que podría tratarse de uno de
los primeros lugares del mundo en
alcanzar a la llamada de inmunidad
colectiva desde el viernes las
autoridades locales se impusieron
medidas restrictivas como la prohibición
de reuniones y restringieron las horas
de funcionamiento de restaurantes y
negocios el informe es de valentina
torres sánchez
la des escalada y va progresando incluso
se ha afirmado que podría ser uno de los
primeros lugares del planeta en alcanzar
la inmunidad de rebaño pero el
resurgimiento de los casos de kobe 19 en
manaos la ciudad más grande de la
amazonas brasileño ha puesto en alerta a
las autoridades
un análisis internacional liderado por
investigadores de la universidad de sao
paulo indica que entre el 44 y el 66% de
la población contrajo el virus entre
mediados de mayo y agosto la cantidad de
pacientes colapso del sistema
hospitalario y los cementerios no daban
abasto sin embargo con el pasar de las
semanas las muertes disminuyeron de 60
decesos diarios en abril pasaron a sólo
dos o tres al final de agosto y la
situación se fue normalizando de a pocos
no obstante los números han vuelto a
aumentar es por ello que desde el
viernes las autoridades locales
decidieron cerrar playas y bares
prohibir reuniones y restringir las
horas de funcionamiento de restaurantes
y tiendas durante 30 días el gobierno
debe tomarse esto en serio y hablar con
la verdad decir lo que está pasando y lo
que no por dos razones problema si dicen
que no hay problema no recibiremos ayuda
si dice que no hay problema eso
impulsará a las personas a ignorar
nuestros decretos
las autoridades han indicado que los
contagios se han incrementado entre
personas jóvenes que asisten a lugares
públicos y desarrollan síntomas leves
sin embargo ellos contagian a familiares
mayores que a menudo terminan bajo
tratamiento hospitalario
y la segunda ciudad más grande de
australia levantó este lunes un toque de
queda nocturno a medida que el estado de
victoria comenzó a reducir las
restricciones por el hobbit 19 melbourne
y sus 5 millones de residentes siguen
bajo la orden de quedarse en casa pero
pueden salir por razones esenciales la
región ha visto una gran disminución en
el número de nuevos contagios veamos
las calles de melbourne una ciudad de 5
millones de habitantes siguen estando en
su mayoría desiertas el lunes se levantó
el toque de queda nocturno después de
casi dos meses pero la orden de quedarse
en casa sigue en vigor algunos
residentes están impacientando con las
restricciones que dicen son demasiado
estrictas dado que sólo se registraron
cinco nuevos contagios por el virus en
el estado de victoria en las últimas 24
horas el encierro durará por lo menos
otros dos meses como dice tan andrés
hasta finales de octubre entonces qué
hacemos de repente no podré pagar el
alquiler y hay millones de personas en
victoria que están en el mismo barco
además de levantar el toque de queda las
industrias de la construcción y la
manufactura pueden volver a funcionar
las guarderías pueden reabrir y los
pequeños servicios religiosos pueden
reanudarse pero los negocios
considerados no esenciales siguen
teniendo prohibido la reapertura los
restaurantes solo están disponibles para
pedidos a domicilio el primer ministro
del estado de victoria advirtió a los
residentes que no se volvieran
complacientes
estamos tan cerca de poder dar un gran
pasó un gran paso hacia esa normalidad
y empezamos a hacer cosas que sabemos en
el fondo que no son correctas entonces
podemos poner en riesgo todo lo que
hemos construido todo lo que los
victoria nos han dado
australia ha sido relativamente exitosa
en frenar la propagación del cob y 19
con poco más de 27.000 contagios y solo
875 de pesos para una población de 25
millones el gobierno de victoria dijo
que una mayor relajación de las medidas
podría tener lugar el 19 de octubre si
el promedio cae por debajo de los 5
nuevos casos por día
y revisemos a esta hora nuestro sitio
web e france24 puntocom en portada usted
puede leer the new york times el revela
información comprometedora sobre los
impuestos de donald trump y macro no le
da a líbano entre 4 y 6 semanas para
formar un nuevo gobierno asimismo
belarús cumple 50 días desde el inicio
de las protestas usted siga con nosotros
en france 24 volvemos en minutos
[Música]